an island nation fighting for its life
the very existence of the maldives is at
stake
not one threat but three
all driven by climate change
azeem mushtag is a marine scientist i've
joined him on an expedition to measure
the health of the archipelago's coral
these reefs are crucial to the atoll
survival an essential part of the entire
marine ecosystem
but the rising sea temperature is
killing the coral reefs and that is
having a devastating impact on life
both on land
and sea
we need to take action really fast and i
don't think
the major countries the major players
are doing much about it so it's quite
likely that within
the next several decades we will lose
our reefs if there is not enough
protection if we want
maldives to be a small dips we need to
act really really fast
the coral also protects the coastline
with it gone the islands are vulnerable
and exposed
when we see acres and acres of
rainforest or jungle lost to
deforestation it prompts and rightly so
a huge global outcry well there's a
similar thing happening here in the
maldives but it's happening
under the water and it's much easier for
the world to ignore
as our planet heats up the sea level
rises data for the maldives shows a
three to four millimeter increase in the
last year alone
that means these low-lying islands could
be completely submerged within the next
decade
there is another perhaps even more
urgent crisis
some of these islands are in danger of
being washed away
here you can see the
the natural erosion line dr abdullah
nasir is gathering data from across the
islands the weather is changing monsoons
and tropical storms are more frequent
and more violent it's causing severe
coastal erosion shrinking the already
under pressure islands
we are losing land not only we are
losing land but we are losing uh
infrastructure and people are losing
their livelihoods as well so we are
concerned that we may have to
move people around you know
consolidate people to different islands
maybe even if we need to evacuate some
of the islands we may have to do that
even
depending on the situation of the island
the scientific evidence is there
has changed
[Music]
the warnings have been sounded for years
and they are coming true
time for the maldives
is running out